why you should not go into consulting
this is the topic for today's video
it's a bit of an unusual topic if you
know the other videos on my channel and
indeed i also want to make the format of
today's video a little bit different
than otherwise
because today i really want to give you
a real talk
i want to show some real stories to you
tell you really about
my personal experiences and thereby talk
about why i really think that for some
people
probably consulting is not the right
thing and also really
explain that to you what really the
downsides of the career are
i hope i also touch a couple of things
which are not the obvious reasons like
you
travel a lot i think we all know this
but let's really go into the details of
this and so indeed
the format i want to do it here today
also in the video format is that i will
just sit down here with you
i wrote a couple of notes here on my
piece of paper and i just really want to
have a
heart to heart conversation with you
which is really frank
probably was a bit less edited this
video than usual so
apologize if maybe i just talk a bit
more
or are less structured than usual
because again this will just be due to
the nature of this video
just because i want to be as frank and
as open as possible with you today
so in the spirit welcome to another
coffee break here on my channel from
learning
i will of course drink coffee
as usual and i will probably put it down
here next to me
or please do not wonder if i'll casually
pick it up again on my channel i want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career and
again just to start this also off to
make sure that i'm not being
misunderstood here
if you've seen other videos on my
channel
you know that i'm in general a very big
fan of consulting i'm a very big
proponent of consulting and this was not
just fake i truly believe that i truly
believe that consulting is a great
extraordinary career opportunity for
many many people out there
i really mean this by heart though it's
not only
positive what you experienced there for
sure i had some dark moments for sure to
me that happened things
which weren't that great and i want to
talk about this as well also on the
channel
just just in terms of being fair right
because i believe that if you decide
yourself to start consulting
then you should know what you're getting
yourself into and then also what maybe
some things are which may be a bit nicer
in other career paths
because of course even though i like
consulting a lot by no means i want to
claim that consulting is the only career
path that you can
pursue to become successful or to be
happy or to have a great life
of course there are many other
alternatives i mean i hope that this is
obvious as well
so let's talk about these things and i
have prepared
three points i want to talk about
and maybe if i just kind of read the
topic of the point
it might sound a bit obvious to you but
again i hope to touch also a couple of
not so obvious points here
and the first point i want to talk about
is
the pressure the pressure that you will
feel when working in consulting
especially also as as a junior really
from the start
and here just really try to put
yourselves
in the shoes of of a young consultant
how will your day
look like and i'm especially as always
talking about these
very large tier one strategy consulting
firms
with some other firms that might be a
bit different of course not all firms
are the same and so on and so forth you
know this right
but let's talk about this type of firm
and indeed they are often
from day one from week one after the
first onboarding days or so
you will be sitting at the client on an
actual client
project and you will have significant
responsibilities
the team sizes are very small on a
typical mbb type of project you will be
one of two three four five consultants
and you will very early on be
responsible for a full
work stream and if for whatever reason
your work stream isn't doing well the
pressure is on
let me just tell you this because
everybody is so loaded so full of work
it's not
the case as in many other larger
companies that your colleagues can just
pick up the work and just help you out
necessarily can just do the work for you
for whatever reason you do not really
manage
of course there will be a project lead
who will coach you who will help you who
will really
benefit you also try to develop you and
in difficult meetings also join you
but even then very early you will have
meetings with also rather senior clients
on many projects
alone you will sit alone with them and
then again for all kinds of reasons it
wouldn't be unusual that maybe a client
isn't happy
with you with your work with the value
that you deliver with the results that
you bring
and he will criticize you and you might
not get a long way with him
or her whatever the client is the client
might complain
to your project lead to your partner and
then
depending on how it goes i mean again
depends on the circumstances but then
rather quickly sometimes you will really
also be very quickly in the focus of the
critique
and if this happens also just mentally
psychologically but can be extremely
tough imagine
going into the team room every day
you're working with clients who you know
don't like you don't appreciate you
don't want to work with you and of
course this also often has
political reasons right some clients
might literally be incentivized
to not make you succeed to make you fail
and of course in an ideal situation your
team will recognize this will help you
out
will support you and this is also how it
is most of the times
but not always and you know this can
really be tough and i also made
a video about that talking about stress
and anxiety in situations like this i
will link it
somewhere above here where i'm sharing
things like this and i was explaining a
bit more also more personal stories
but i mean i can tell you let me be
honest here i had projects where i
really
just felt like so miserable like also
psychologically so bad i remember one
time i just
went to the client toilet locked myself
into a
toilet cabin and just because i couldn't
handle the situation anymore in the team
room sitting together with the
colleagues
just coming out of a client meeting just
really being heavily criticized by the
client
and then also often feeling powerless
because
i mean sometimes of course the criticism
is right but especially as a junior
you then lack sometimes also the the
political agility to really play this in
the right way
there are also things that are out of
your control and very frankly i've seen
colleagues
who just were crushed by that i mean who
really spent like one or two years
in this atmosphere and really
psychologically mentally
probably even had like some more or less
like lasting damages from that because
it can be like extremely
difficult extremely tough and if you do
not develop some
some really mental resilience strategies
then this can really take a toll on you
and again now i also don't take me wrong
i
i don't want to not make consigning
sound like
mental abuse or anything like that i
mean clearly there are many many other
things where you have
much worse experience than what you can
experience there but again i think on
some people it can be extremely tough
extremely difficult i for sure had
my dark moments as well i believe
there's like
almost no concern for sure no consultant
i personally know
who didn't have like ones or two
situations on projects
but i really feel badly also really
mentally for for all kinds
of reasons of course the great thing in
consulting is that then
after the project is always the next
project where you then work with a new
team
with a new client with the new situation
and also here in terms of your career
only
if you fail on one project for whatever
reason this doesn't mean that you need
to leave the firm or that you need to
get kicked out or whatever right i mean
it's not like that
but still this mental pressure is a
thing and i also like to compare this to
some other jobs because i mean there are
jobs where
you just go into the office you sit down
there
you do your work and then at five or six
pm
you leave the office and then at home
there's really nothing else you need to
think about anymore
like you have like an empty head you
know these are these more
if you want to call it this way simple
jobs i don't know don't mean this in any
derogatory way
but this for sure is not how your job in
consulting will be i mean you will
leave the office you will sit at your
desk at night late at night still
continue to work potentially late after
midnight
next morning back in the team room and
then on the friday on the weekend
yes like there is a strong culture at
least what i experienced to not work on
the weekend
but for sure you're already thinking of
monday i mean clearly it's not a job
where you just have an empty head once
you're home or anything like this
especially if you compare this to some
other careers
so this is the first truth the first
downside the first thing you need to be
aware of this pressure
and of course many things i just talked
about are very closely and directly
related also to the learning curve
i mean these are situations just why you
learn so much i mean
it is just because you are under so much
pressure that you develop yourself in
such a quick way that you need to
learn this political game you need to
learn to interacting with senior clients
that have their own agenda and so on i
mean also again you need to understand
that this is
closely linked right but still this is
part of the reality as well
this is what it is so hope i didn't now
already talk too much and too long here
i have a bit of a feeling this one might
get into a bit of a longer video but let
me know
take a zip of coffee here
and because of the second point i want
to talk about the second thing that
i believe really people underestimate is
this travel aspect and i know i said
this in the beginning that i don't want
to
talk too much about the obvious stuff so
let's cover that quickly first right so
i mean what is the obvious stuff
about the whole travel discussion of
course you will be away from home monday
to thursday
again i will link another video up here
where i talked about the typical work
week in the life of a consultant so this
interests you
how like the schedule looks like where
you are at what point in time
at least especially like until end of
2019 before the current health situation
of course most people are at home office
but for this place i would um
have a look at that video but what i
really mean with the travel is that
it's really more than that right and of
course the one part of it is that it can
be
very glamorous and you know you might
fly business class around the country a
lot of course that feels glamorous you
have all the status cards of all the
airlines of all the big hotel chains
you might stay in some great very very
amazing hotels
these are the nice aspects and yes this
is nice and
even after several years i still enjoyed
that okay i mean with the dancer of
course that you are away from home away
from the family this is still a nice
aspect
but still the rarity is that not every
project
is in a nice big city where you have
this infrastructure where you can enjoy
all this
and for me probably at least every third
or every fourth project for me
was at some place very deep like in the
middle of nowhere
in the countryside where it was really
difficult to get
to i mean i remember being like at some
very very rural location in the uk
there was only a discount carrier taking
you there so for sure nothing like
business class or any like great status
with launches or so experience at the
airport
then there was a long ride with the with
a car than really to get that location
on the logistics would take you hours
every day
would mean that you would need to wake
up i believe i was waking up on 4 am
every monday just to get there
and then was like super late when i
arrived back on thursday
but then also these places often there
aren't great hotels
or anything like that so especially at
this point i was
on a hotel it was like really not a
great italian i'm i'm not like
it's not even that you know i'm the guy
who to whom it is so important that it's
so luxurious or whatever
but it was really not a great place it
was in the winter it was cold i remember
freezing at night because the heating in
this hotel wasn't working properly
i just needed to like take several
sweatshirts on just because i was
literally
freezing there right the food was super
bad there was
not any restaurant close by that had
really like a decent food quality
and of course this is so demoralizing if
you know you work so much you work so
late and you
are in the hotel room and then it's cold
and the food is bad
and i mean this just adds so much to
this also really mental pressure that
you have
and again there are some glamorous parts
sometimes it can be great again i had
great experiences in amazing hotels of
course these are the nice sides
but don't underestimate how many also
very big very large companies
have sometimes their headquarters at
very very rural places
or of course you are not always at the
headquarters maybe you are working in in
in production and then you are in some
production factory somewhere in the
middle of nowhere working with these
people
um it can be tough and this again adds
to this mental situation to the pressure
it adds to this overall sometimes really
really bad situation that you can then
find yourself
in this is just also part of the reality
this was
the second point i wanted to share here
today
the third point is
the learning curve and specifically
what's maybe not so great
about the learning curve because most
people want to join consulting who are
interested in a career in consulting do
this because they believe
that the learning curve is amazing and
again like
overall i agree overall i believe the
learning curve
is great it's amazing at least much
better than most other career paths that
you can take
because specifically you just have
exposure to
a very high number of industries a very
high number of different
functions like probably there's no other
career path where like in a couple of
years
you will likely have worked in retail in
automotive in
pharma and telecommunications i mean
what you see what you can do is great
though still
to some extent it does get repetitive
this is also part of the truth and
probably this is even
worse in for instance i.t consulting
types of firms where the projects are
even longer
the type of projects that you do are
even more similar but i would argue even
in
strategy consulting with mbb type of
consulting firms
it gets repetitive not necessarily
regarding the
the contents that you do because often
yes it is different but even here over
time you will be asked to specialize
more and more
after two or three years you will really
focus much
more on specific industries specific
types
of functions of types of projects
because of course this is then where you
build knowledge and then of course
everybody wants you to do this again
because this is really something you've
learned and you're really good at i mean
it makes sense but of course then the
contents start to repeat after some time
but even if you do do different things
the overall structure the type of things
that you do
are very similar i mean always like in
the first week
you always have a client kickoff right
so you prepare this client kickoff
then you start the project you have
expert calls calls with internal experts
other partners who do
similar things already in the past maybe
some external aspects
experts that you talk to this is then
this next phase then you have
your weekly draw fixed meetings your
weekly regular meetings with the clients
but then you always prepare this through
a fixed document you talk about this
with the client
then you prepare your analysis get some
data build an excel model crunch the
numbers derive this
share this back with a client discuss it
then every second week you have a steer
co
so it's a big steering committee the big
committee where usually with what level
type of members you're discussing the
results
again the process is always the same the
partner comes in discuss
this with you then do an iteration loop
another iteration loop until you have
the document then present it in front of
the board get the feedback
so this kind of type of activities that
you do these types of discussions
it really starts to get repetitive after
some point
again probably much more interesting
than many other career jobs
but after you did this a couple of years
it doesn't necessarily feel
like this anymore like the very first
time like the very first years to do
this and of course this is also part of
the reason but then after a couple of
years
many people do switch right many people
do then transition
and of course then once your project
lead the new experience that you add is
really managing the team leading the
team this is a new experience
once you are then a partner here the new
experiences really are
responsible for acquiring your business
doing sales if you want to call it this
way
of course this is your new experience
but i would argue
depending on what exactly then you do
but then there are some exit paths
that you could take that really then
increase your learning curve much more
and here one of the things i missed most
in terms of consulting in terms of the
learning
for sure was really this operational
experience because let's be frank it's
very different to just be the
expert just tell other people in a smart
way what they should do
you know this is one thing and of course
this is important and a great skill to
have you understand intellectually
what's right but they're really
implementing something like this
in an organization talking to the people
making them do the things that you want
them to do
all of this might sound obvious to you
as a consultant and probably i even
thought that this was
rather easy you know when i was a
consulter but now after a couple of
years and more operational roles
after i have consulting so you know i
worked for two years at a
at a cto position in a retail company
now
since this year i transitioned into a
chief revenue officer position at a
medium-sized company here in munich
when you're responsible for your team
when you need to talk and work with real
people
and maybe then also with people where
not everybody has an ivy league
education
where not everybody is getting paid a
six-digit
salary because of course these people
are then super motivated will do
everything you ask them to do right
but maybe with people also with other
profiles motivating these people
influencing them to really work together
with you on the things that are
important to you and then also that they
do it the way that you believe is right
and you know it's right
this is really a significant challenge
and i really think that
this is an experience that you do not
learn do not get in considering
because therefore you often just stops
in the theory at least for most
types of projects so this is
my third point let me just recap first
the pressure that you are on early on
can be immense can be unbearable at
least it feels at times that it's
unbearable
and can really crush you especially if
you are like your mental
health isn't already in a strong place
in the beginning you're not really able
to build some
good resilience strategies here second
this travel
that just adds on it can be really
really tough on you
and third the solar repetition yes the
learning curve is great
but maybe not always as great as you
think it is or as you think it will be
when you join consulting these are my
truths
these are the things where i believe
that maybe consulting is not the right
career path for everybody and at least i
believe it's very fair that you know
about this
before you start your career in
consulting
this is just my perspective my opinion
of course i trust other people might
have had different experiences also so
i'm not claiming that this is now the
reality the truth for everybody
i'd love to get your perspective on that
as well i mean what were these
maybe darker moments darker situations
not so great
experiences that you had let me know in
the comments i'd love to
to to interact with you on that as you
know i will do my best to answer every
comment but i trust it would also be
interesting to other people who watch
this video
to learn from your other experiences as
well and
you know it as always if you took some
value out of this video i'd really love
you if you
hit the like button and subscribe for
more content like this
also a big thank you to all the members
of firm learning for your support i
really appreciate it
my name is heinrich i release weekly
videos here on my channel
firm learning so stay tuned until next
week until next saturday
all the best to you this is heine from
from learning and bye bye